welcome to this video not kovitch okay
no no vegan flag okay i'm going to play
loop Jeff Knight f3 I mean I have played
so many names of games that feel like a
change sir may be in order okay so okay
I just taking a 94 yes this is certainly
certainly a line cook see one I guess
not played knight c6 interesting ok so
that's a uncommon combination taking on
c3 and then going for a d5 set up but of
course black is fairly solid so it's not
a mistake or anything you know it's
probably worse than the d65 set up okay
so taking now let's see do I want to
take with the Queen oyster look yeah and
he's nice ideas to play a 5 take and
then play you five
yeah that's it's okay you can get this
in okay what if i take with the pollicis
maybe a little bit more aggressive it
doesn't really look look very fetching
okay so instead of taking an e5 he's
doing that not a move that I expected
does this just looks better for wide in
some form it's just just a question how
much but how do you play Bishop a6 some
I move that he wants to play Bishop a6
bishop yeah if it were they should be on
Princess seven and this okay I want to
cover e to now maybe here
Jim Scott Roxy aid coming
yeah p equalized with this business be
6mm look-see to maybe not precise I
don't know I'm a bit I'm a bit surprised
that I couldn't really maintain any any
kind of any kind of play it just
completely completely equal
strange maybe look see to us wasn't the
best or no or taking I don't know it may
experience in these kind of positions is
somewhat limited I have over the years
almost exclusively played the names oh
so those queens in the entire positions
Queens Indian Go Go Indian is I mean I
know the bogo with with g6 this kind of
things but this type of position is not
really chat something that I know much
about now ok this is this is just equal
can I do something anything hey 95 it's
probably mostly kind of a demonstration
which is not leading to much she was
like f forms is doing you much good
now wait this is a cannibal unlucky
unlucky a position night see force maybe
Jack maybe something that I should take
into account what i'm doing here is
mostly provoking provoking him to do
something I don't know if I is this a
good idea if I am if I is a good move I
super stupid stupid stupid stupid okay
maybe it's it's still it's still not so
bad because I have we should be three
but yeah yeah i was i was just now that
was a bad idea just staying would've
them are just staying doing nothing
would have been would have been right
okay i can just about not losing loose
stuff iam
yeah maybe maybe this is this is
something something interesting take 93
now well I cannot play for win in this
position what would be quite remarkable
I can give the chicken now and at the
end night h5 say is Bishop f7 of course
I will that was again a very stupid idea
yeah he has Bishop f7 in any case my
kind of stupid okay why have 36 seconds
first time I look on the clock I much
down on time okay I don't need to do
anything here
the position itself is just a draw but
the 30 seconds are tricky i wonder if i
should play g4 or not okay that question
is now out of the picture if you take
site a key forwards check so
okay i have no way forward TM
unfortunately with the the King sitting
down
d5 d6 maybe
maybe a missus is a valid winning tribe
no can fi if he could have done and now
i'm playing for win here check checkmate
okay we that was close yeah well winning
it's hard to believe but it was just a
draw it was just wrong thank you yeah I
played I played some stupid movie and
this in this completely equal position I
was kind of I didn't want to do nothing
but what I did is really a bit it was
this was kind of stupid okay allowing
allowing this thing here it was not
really it's probably no problem but it's
a it's a bit weird to to allow that okay
so maybe I have some some better moves
here the compounds to play G for an
interesting move for neither form I
don't get it completely what is the big
point of this move this one
this is still nothing check yeah and
here it's really just just this is just
a kind of a fortress where both sides
don't don't really have any progress to
make I got this gotcha for and maybe I
could have it could have done it here
right it is probably leads to the same
thing and again it's just a draw I can
just shuffle and but here yeah this was
interesting I could have played a good
play I could play this one and this sets
em some problems Bishop c4 is a draw
this is a drawn okay but here I'm
actually getting somewhere okay yeah i
can take b5 of course but 15 seconds him
i really wasn't a huge premium oh I
wanted to initially he go over here but
this is stupid yeah TM he completely
fell apart and even gave me the bishop
so yeah klosterman was tough with the
seven seconds but ultimately it was a
win this is a pretty nice serious right
okay six wins that's nice okay well
thanks for watching